all right Kayla Kayla where you from
orgin where'd you grow up Tacoma
Washington and then when I was 15 I
moved to Pew allop Washington state that
is tell me about your family growing up
um
unfortunately um I didn't really have a
good childhood thanks to my dad he was
uh very abusive towards me and my mom I
don't talk to him this day but my mom uh
me and her have a very good relationship
always have how would you describe your
childhood in general childhood um up
until the um age N I think my dad left
but up until then it was it was
especially when I was 7 it was really
tough a lot of uh bad things happened
not like not like sexually or anything
but uh yeah my dad he he was just a
monster
um like chaos in the house it sounds
yeah he's just a very angry
person yeah what kind of girl you in
high school um I kind of I was a social
social
butterfly I always had friends in every
one of the
clicks and how did how did you end up
getting introduced to this line of
work um I started online I used to stay
uh live in five and I did online with
like Mega personal skip the game
what age was that um that was about a
year and a half ago oh so you didn't get
started early you got started late yeah
where did your life leave at After High
School oh After High School
um After High School I became homeless
when I was
20 and I was homeless for like eight
years were drugs a part of your life huh
were drugs a part of your life uh back
then they aren't now mhm
um I got like two years clean good so
but I my whole 20s I was homeless pretty
much from 20 to 28 and pup Sumer
oring what was your
drug um it started out with uh weed of
course I started that when I was like 13
and then uh it progressed uh to Like
Cocaine when I was 16 and then um when I
was like 21
I started using meth and then um just a
couple week or not weeks but a couple
years ago like almost four years ago I
started using heroin and then the pills
came out and I was doing those and then
I stopped those and then I did a little
bit of
fentanyl with the pills and you're clean
now yes do you have
children um yes I do and are you where
are they um they are back in Washington
but I keep close contact with them
they're staying with your family yeah
yeah so you you started doing this kind
of work just to um I like the
money
survival yeah is you find it's better
money than you can get with a regular
job um
sometimes tell me about the uh the men
who are your clients oh um I've come
across uh some really nice gentlemen and
then I've come across um and put in bad
situations unfortunately I uh when I was
staying in F I got raped
twice um un you know wrong place wrong
time wrong dude that I got I'm a I got a
bad picker I guess what what is it about
this this line of this kind of work that
that works for you most most women would
say this just doesn't work for me it's
too dangerous it's it's too degrading
it's too whatever yeah um Easy Money
easy money you find that once you get
over the hurdle of that first time of
doing it for money that it becomes
easier um yes it does become
easier it's a little rocky in the
beginning cuz um a lot of uh what is
that
like self-conscience you know you almost
are like fighting yourself you know
talking to yourself what should I be
doing
this yeah so now you're working online
mostly or on the streets um on the
streets and you work with a pimp or
without you know I don't want to put a
title on it but I'm taken care of and
got the right protection so yep I
understand and so back to your clients
they they're how many of them you think
are married um a good probably a good
portion of them they actually told me
themselves that they are married and
that makes it a little awkward but I get
over it quickly I'm just like oh okay
and what do you what do you make of that
does that does that affect the way you
no see relationships uh well yeah of
course it does but I don't let it affect
me
the guys will come to your do you have a
room or you you go you go to a car or uh
mostly car date sometimes they'll uh pay
for a hotel room for like an hour or
whatever was this kind of work due to
you emotionally um sometimes it's um
satisfying like I'll be really happy if
I make a good amount of money um other
times I get discouraged because uh
there's a lot of other girls out there
that look better than me you know and so
it's like a competition almost but I I
don't see it as a competition but or I
like to call it a fashion show it looks
like a fashion show sometimes yeah it
does out there uh the other girls are
competitive or they're friendly are
they're nice help um some of them don't
I'll say something to them like hi how
you doing you know and some will um they
call it uh
socializing
and some of them don't respond because
um they don't want to or and some of
them are really
nice yeah I guess it's it's probably
like your like your clientele it's a
mixed bag of everything yeah yeah do you
think prostitution should be
legalized um
yeah it's almost like you're providing a
service for for men that are customer
service yeah well I know but sometimes
these guys are
so a lot of them are
probably they have a lot of worked up
emotions that they don't know how to
deal with yeah and they're not going to
do you recall your first time doing this
um yeah yeah I was uh I was really
really
shy uh and um I think uh the guy kind of
took advantage of that because he's like
oh this girl must be
new um but thank God I had it um my part
uh one of my girlfriends with me because
it was an online
thing so I just did Duos with her for uh
the majority of me starting for the
first like seven to eight months I did
online work with one of my girlfriends
back in Washington we were staying in F
at the time though were there were there
other things you want to do with your
life oh yes of course um my dream job
was um an x-ray technician
um I have my Gad I just haven't uh
really thought about going back to
school do you believe in karma yes I do
how does karma play into this whole
world that you're in um Karma um I
believe you do uh do people how they do
you so like if somebody does me good
then I'm going to treat them good and if
they do me bad then I mean Karma will
get
him some people might say that
you're you're sleeping with other
women's
husbands um well they should um their
wives better uh they're coming to me for
some reason that something that their
wife isn't
doing does it does it make you question
the uh the whole idea of marriage oh
yeah I know I'm never going to get
married in this
lifetime relationship it's overrated
kind of there's no morals and yeah
nobody takes it seriously anymore M like
they did back then right is this a
lonely life for you um
no how does it affect your self
self-esteem um you get guys like saying
oh you're beautiful yeah all the time
all the time it affects it um greatly
like I feel good about myself um
everybody has their days though
sometimes I'll not feel as pretty as I
did you know like a couple days
before but I just but then the guys are
also picking you up and taking you
around the corner and doing some
business and then you're yeah you're out
of the car again yeah that's got to
impact your selfesteem as well yeah yeah
um it makes me feel uh like uh
um discouraged like um like I'll be
standing with like other girls and um I
thought they were like they're giving
making eye contact with me so that's why
I walked up to the car and uh you know
they want they want the other girl you
know which is fine it's totally how the
game works I guess but that's how the
world works yeah yeah I don't I try not
to take it too personal yeah that's you
developed a thick skin doing this right
yeah you got to you got to got to stay
strong what's your what's your biggest
regret what what would you have done
have done differently you um I would to
live again I would
have
um stayed out of trouble I wouldn't have
been homeless that's one of my biggest
regrets is becoming homeless cuz it had
a really uh deep impact on my life did
you find your like you when you started
this kind of work work your back was
against the wall and you just needed
money quickly and um yeah is that what
it was
yeah did you consider how crazy this
this kind of work is though uh yes um
one incident like uh my second day here
in Los Angeles um I got into the car
with someone and um a bullet went right
through the back window I guess it was
his wife or something but yeah it
shattered the glass and that scared me
really
bad and then I had another incident this
was like less than a week ago where
um a black guy got out of his car and he
like tried to pull me to his car he's
like get in the car and smacked my
phone out of my hand and uh my friend
was with me and she he's like if you
call anybody I'll kill you or I'll kill
her that was scary that was scary it got
my adrenaline pumping pretty bad
how do you think working the streets is
changing
you um it's making me
tougher I used to be really sensitive
but I'm getting I'm getting there and
being tough is a a good thing or a bad
thing a good thing is it yeah not like
overly tough like to where you're to
where I'd be a to everybody but
like um in the right circumstance um you
know just not taking any you know
having boundaries and stuff like that
does that make sense yeah okay you think
you're addicted to the the fast
money um yeah a little bit Yeah it' be
hard for you to quit
um no I mean no it wouldn't be hard for
me to quit maybe it would be I haven't
really thought about stopping I know I'm
not going to do this forever
but someday I'll
stop do you ever think uh you deserve a
better life life than than being a girl
the
streets I don't really think
uh I mean I have a pretty good life
right now it was a lot better than where
I was at before I came
um to work on the streets
mhm do you believe in love now uh yeah
for some people like uh not in love but
like having love for uh like family and
friends of
course what advice would you give to a
girl who's
considering doing this kind of work uh
just to be careful and always have like
um condoms and make sure that uh you
have pepper spray cuz some of these guys
are weirdos out there and they'll try to
you know pull something like try to rape
you or choke you or hit you or just so
just be careful you get some of these
guys asking you for things that are
riskier than you're comfortable doing
yeah all the time like some of them want
to kiss or like uh do like inappropriate
things like kissing is like real
personal I think and um I don't I don't
let them go down on me
either because I I just explained I'm uh
supposed to be pleasuring you not you
pleasuring me
type
thing Kay what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life um most important
lesson uh to just uh like when I fall
just to get back up and like don't let
anything hold me down don't care too
much about what other people think and
uh just stay strong
all right Kayla thank you so much for
sharing your story was that good it was
good okay thank you very much did I come
off nervous no you're fine
okay